[Music]
i started visual communication at the
music poly
this was from 1993 to 95
the first 10 years of my career i was
really doing just graphic design
what i learned in school and then i
worked in advertising agencies
and soon after i started my own practice
asylum
the kind of projects that we started
working on a lot of it
is really for the retail industry for
fmv industry
and you know things that i really love
and as
i was designing the branding and
different visual aspects of it
i felt that the space was really crucial
to a brand's perspective
so it's not really just you know the
logo or the website
and hence from then onwards we started
to look at a more holistic approach
when it comes to design
[Music]
one of the earliest projects that we
started working on was a brand called
frolic
and this is a frozen yogurt brand and as
we were thinking
of you know different directions of how
we bring this brand to life
we looked at visual cues and we looked
at how
the the shop experience should be fun so
we took the opportunity of kind of
looking
at just purely graphic design to working
on the more holistic approach in looking
at interior design
looking at the digital experience so
from that small little project we kind
of
grew bolder and then slowly i guess we
got more opportunity
our biggest break was in shanghai where
we won the project to do sony gallery
which is a purely interior design
project
we had not much of an experience but we
took on the challenge
and we worked with an architect from
america and we collaborated hence we
kind of
learned hands on how do you work on a
proper interior space
i guess designers today could
collaborate a lot more
than the past because the projects tend
to be multifaceted
and they're just a lot more complicated
so you either
collaborate with partners that you can
work with
or you expand your kind of team so that
you can tackle
a lot more disciplines within one
project
[Music]
before i went on to the school of design
i
was think i was i just wanted to design
cd covers i thought i love
music and i look at album covers and wow
this is a great
career i could do that by going to the
school of design i'm exposed to
different disciplines like architecture
like photographers it really opened up
a big door for me to explore and which
is why i guess when i started
my career i did not want to be kind of
you know
pigeon hole into a certain discipline or
category
i get inspired by fashion designers i
get inspired by architects
i get inspired by you know artists
if you are 20 years old you should just
go and do whatever you want
you shouldn't be so fixated at what you
learn rather what you have
learned is the foundation where you can
really break free
don't be afraid of failure don't be
afraid of changing
just really explore but i think once you
find that love then you know dive
right into it